bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission dans laquelle on va vous parler
d'économie réelle et non pas de science
fiction comme monsieur le maire
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des prêts garantis par l'état et
des entreprises
évidemment qui les reçoivent bonjour
estelle bonjour olivier bonjour à tous
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de ses
caches consacré olivier vous l'a dit aux
prêts et garanties par l'état à cette
mesure phare du plan de soutien aux
entreprises impactées à par la pandémie
alors est-ce une bonne stratégie pour
l'état de venir en aide aux entreprises
de la sorte quelles seront les
conséquences
à l'avenir on va faire le point dans
cette émission et puis pour en parler
nous serons en deuxième partie avec
stéphane petit bon enseignant en
économie et finance
jusqu'au 30 juin 2021 les entreprises
françaises touchées par la pandémie
peuvent bénéficier de prêts garantis par
l'état en 2000 26 130 mille entreprises
ont fait appel à ce dispositif 89%
d'entre elles ont un chiffre d'affaires
inférieur à 2 millions d'euros
si sur les 630 mille la part des grandes
entreprises représentaient 0 2%
le montant de leurs prêts accordés lui
représente 12% de l' enveloppe globale
distribué par les établissements
bancaires 12% soit environ à 15
milliards d'euros selon les chiffres du
ministère de l'économie à leur dernière
grande entreprise en date à avoir obtenu
un pg e le groupe lagardère voyez cela
avec le tiroir cash d'antoine d'assas
[Musique]
c'est une somme rondelette pour laquelle
l'état se porte garant pour le groupe
lagardère à 465 millions d'euros 10 pge
prêts garantis par l'état dirigé par
arnaud lagardère le groupe comporte
notamment les éditions hachette les
boutiques de gare ou aéroport rôle et où
plusieurs médias comme europe 1 paris
match le jdd et avec
énorme en 2020 arnaud lagardère peut
pousser un gros soupir de soulagement
même si le groupe ne peut pas rembourser
la note
l'état s'engage à payer la majeure
partie du crédit 80% et par l'état
entendait bien évidemment vous et moi re
mais alors comment le groupe lagardère
en est-il arrivé là
officiellement ce serait le coc vide
comme toujours et gardons le dos
celui-là bon c'est sûr que posséder un
groupe de boutiques d'aéroports et de
gars quand on n'a pas le droit de
voyager ça doit pas aider à booster un
chiffre d'affaires après avoir vu ses
revenus chuter de 55% au premier
semestre
ce pan du groupe s'est effondré à la fin
de l'année de 66% pour plafonner à moins
de 400 millions d'euros de revenus à
côté de ça arnaud lagardère subit aussi
la fronde de deux actionnaires de son
groupe vincent bolloré le groupe vit
vingt dix son ancien pote et alliés et
le fonds d'investissement ambert qui
remettent tous deux en cause la gestion
fils héritier fiscalité qui au passage a
également une situation personnelle pas
très folichonne avec plus de 160
millions d'euros de dettes auprès du
crédit agricole
pour ce qui est de ses entreprises en
tout cas
reste à voir si ce fameux prêts garantis
par l'état suffira à donner un peu de
moore groupe lagardère et à ses salariés
rien n'est moins sûr mais en tout cas
pour ses actionnaires bonne nouvelle
contractez un pg e impose de ne pas
verser de dividende
uniquement l'année du prêtre et ce même
s'il a été effectuée en toute fin
d'année 2020 comme c'est le cas ici
à défaut de sauver les emplois du groupe
il faudra se contenter de ça
olivier 465 millions d'euros de prêts
dont 80 % garanti par l'état le groupe
lagardère en 2019 c'est 7,2 milliards
d'euros à deux chiffres d'affaires
pourtant en loire les grosses
entreprises semblent avoir eu du mal à
résister à la crise sanitaire mais pour
autant il a bon dos le cou vide nous dit
le tiroir cash vous êtes d'accord
oui je suis d'accord c'est un peu ce
prêt à au groupe lagardère est un prêt
politique c'est pas prêt économique
c'est un prêt politique pourquoi parce
que cette société est propriétaire d'un
certain nombre de titres de journaux et
que monsieur macro on va en avoir bien
besoin pour sa campagne
donc il sait pas un prêt en fait c'est
un don c'est un don à un groupe en
échange d'avoir de bons articles dans la
presse
sinon c'était une entreprise qui était
mal gérée depuis que arnaud lagardère la
reprise c'est mal géré et on le sait ça
fait un moment ça fait un moment que
cette entreprise trébuche et ça n'a rien
à voir avec le co vide et donc ni avant
ni après le l'entreprise va se
transformer sous prétexte d'un prêt
qu'ovide relayant passe tout de suite à
la deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec stéphane petit bonbon jour vous
êtes enseignant en économie et finance
vous aussi administrateur et risk
managers dans un fonds d'investissement
merci beaucoup à d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
bonjour ou peut-être monsieur petibon
une réaction à ce que vous avez entendu
en première partie un sur l'analyse
d'olivier notamment sur le groupe
lagardère finalement ce qu'on comprend
c'est que ce recours au pge ne prend
finalement pas en compte que les
problèmes liés à l'arrivée du code vide
bien sûr que non là il ya eu 130
milliards de verser aux entreprises en
prêts garantis par l'état
bien entendu beaucoup de d'entreprise
qui n'était pas rentable avant commis 19
ou en tout cas qui étaient à peine l
équilibre ont bénéficié de cette aide de
trésorerie mais je vais quand même
rajouter trois points importants sur les
prêts garantis par l'état le premier
mois c'était un thème plutôt dans vos
techniques mais disons que mes confrères
dans le commissariat aux comptes c dans
l'est dans la finance se pose un
problème quand même qui est important
c'est que le pge est un prêt court terme
donc c'est un effet de commerce s'était
fait de commerce est accordée pour un an
et ensuite le ministre des finances a
parlé d'une possibilité proroger ce prêt
sur deux ou trois ans or il n'est pas
possible puisque laon par ce fonds
passerait sur ce qu'on appelle des prêts
investissement sans actifs au bout donc
tu abordes ça pose un problème d'ordre
réglementaire ce plan comptable
bon ça c'est le premier point important
dpj
le deuxième bien entendu 130 milliards
dans les dents une projection d'être
public qui sera aux alentours de 130 %
parce qu'on est à 115% d'être sûr pipe
on va être à 130%
il est clair que c'est pas moi qui l'ait
qui est soulevé ce problème mais le
directeur général de la bnp
post 2 se pose des questions s'il y
avait des faïences il va y avoir des
faïences de l'ordre de on est un peu
d'insolvabilité de l'ordre de 20% chez
actuellement dans les bases risque 20%
et de défaillances par par secteurs
d'activité comme l'hôtellerie la
restauration de l'ordre de 30 donc
forcément c'est des têtes qui vont être
retrouvés dans les banques en suit donc
la question que se pose la direction
générale question qui a été posée
d'ailleurs on n'a pas entendu on n'a pas
encore entendu la réponse des ministères
des finances
c'est en cas de défaillance est ce que
véritablement l'état lève sa garantie et
rembourse aux banques
c'est alors on a estimé aux alentours de
30 voire 40 milliards possible de prêt
qui malheureusement ne sont jamais
remboursés et donc vont se retrouver en
provisions d'aig dans l'est dans les
bilans des banques
et ils savent c'est la question qui va
être posée en fin 2021 et 2022 donc ça
c'est le deuxième problème majeur le
troisième est seul a été soulevée bien
entendu par olivier delamarche
il est clair que je prendre un autre
exemple que celui de lagardère
les galeries lafayette ont perdu presque
50% du chiffre d'affaires
on leur a accordé 300 millions de pge je
vois pas financièrement comment on peut
compenser 300 millions avec une perte
d'un milliard cinq
voilà donc tous à tous ces questions qui
sont des questions factuelles soit d'or
de comptabilité analytique financières
soient financiers on n'a pas de réponse
donc olivier stéphane thibault a nommé
les galeries l'a fait mais on peut aussi
évoquer renouer avec un pg e 2,5
milliards d'euros 4 milliards à pour air
france 500 millions pour un final darty
concrètement c'est selon c'est une
erreur de stratégie de la part de l'état
de prêter des montants de pare de
garantir des montants pareil
auprès des entreprises de stratégie
c'est de les empêcher de travailler et
parce que sinon on n'aurait pas besoin
de leur prêter de l'argent
si elle continue à travailler si elle
continue à en gagner de l'argent non sur
sur le problème de deux sociétés comme
comme air france ou de sociétés comme
comme renault c'est c'est que leur
problème ne vient pas du coc vide
le problème de ces sociétés là il est il
est là depuis longtemps il existe depuis
longtemps
ça fait longtemps que renault ne gagne
pas d'argent en vendant des voitures
nissan en gagnant un peu mais renault
n'ont donc
et là on feint de le découvrir et enfin
de dire oui mais c'est le co vide et à
ce moment là on prête 4 milliards à
renault mais qu'ils vont les bouffer les
4 milliards ils vont les bouffer et puis
il y aura rien la sortie c'est à dire
quand vous ne changez pas de modèle
c'est pas c'est pas simplement l'arrêt
du coc vie qui va relancer les choses
le renault avait avant le coc vide un
modèle économique qui lui fait faire des
pertes et il l'aura toujours après
locaux vides
donc ça ne change rien et de l'huile
d'olives vertes des milliards c'est
idiot c'est olivier prenons l'exemple
d'air france air france les déplacements
ont été interdits pendant pendant les
le confinement notamment ses fins il
assez là pour le coup c'est air france
estelle tous les dix ans tous les dix
ans l'état reprend les pertes d'air
france air france n'a pas perdu de la
évidemment ils en ont perdu plus cette
fois ci avec le co vide mais ça fait
longtemps qu air france nationalise ses
pertes et privatiser des gains donc on
est dans une dans une situation où air
france tous les dix ans fait appel à
l'état et c'est l'état donc vous payez
rassurez-vous vous payer deux fois votre
voyage une fois en achetant le billet et
une fois en recapitalisant air france
tous les dix ans donc il n'y a rien de
nouveau sous le soleil
alors ce merveilleux que vide va
permettre à nos dirigeants pendant des
années encore croyez moi à se trouver un
prétexte pour toutes les bêtises qu'ils
auront fait depuis 20 ans et ils vont
nous sortir du colis dont on va manger
du coc vide pendant un bon moment
stéphane de s'évanouir et agiraient ce
qu'est ce que d'y arriver mais je vais
je vais donner un exemple très factuelle
de cette logique dans une société qu'il
est pas privé mais qui est soumis aux
règles de comptabilité du crc 99 02 s'il
ya des règles comptables et des règles
financières qui devait respecter
j'ai l'occasion une fois de discuter
avec le commissaire aux comptes qui
valide les comptes de la sncf que rien
il ya un débat il suffit de regarder ce
qui s'était passé d'ailleurs à l'époque
avec le sénat et les entretiens du sénat
quand ils ont découvert ils ont
découvert que la dette générale de la
sncf était de 54 milliards c'était
considérables s'ils avaient localisé 20
milliards dans un système à deux pour
qu'ils n'y étaient pas d autoriser à
faire mais ils l'ont fait quand même et
de l'autre côté moi je pensais et quand
j'ai en lui les bilans d'une façon très
précise
le total des actifs était de hauteur de
30 milliards donc la conclusion c'est
que la sncf il ya deux ans et demi était
en dépôt de bilan pour le cas également
de
air france c'est exactement pareil nous
sommes en phase de société qui
comptablement financièrement sont en
dépôt de bilan et ils s'entendaient
dépôt de bilan avant même le kobe de 19
bon c'est clair et cette expression et
j'en terminerai là dessus j'aime bien
cette expression car il était employé
d'ailleurs en 2007 2008
on s'est aperçu que les ténue que
lorsque la marée s'est retiré bien sûr
quand le marché se retire on s'aperçoit
les entreprises qui ont constitué des
réserves financières suffisantes ce qui
est la règle générale quand on gère bien
et d'en devenir une entreprise et les
sociétés qui n'ont aucune réserve
financière et qui vivent comme ça avec
des taux de rentabilité de 2 3% ou moins
3% par an et qui ont fait des dettes
considérables depuis depuis à peu près
une dizaine d'années
mais si on va marquer une courte pause
et on revient dans un instant bienvenue
dans ces caches si vous nous rejoignez
au sommaire cette semaine on va parler
des prêts garantis par l'état et pour
cela nous sommes en liaison avec et
stéphane petit bon enseignant en finance
et économie mais aussi administrateur et
risk managers dans un fonds
d'investissement olivier pour revenir
sur les risques de ces prêts garantis
par l'état concrètement est ce que
l'état joue gros et qu'est ce qui se
passe si ces entreprises ne peuvent pas
rembourser
mais l'état joue gros dans un système
qui serait un système normal y jouerez
go
aujourd'hui on est sortis de ce système
là puisque vous avez des banques
centrales qui
qui imprime tant qu'elles peuvent donc
vous soutenez artificiellement un
système qui est mort donc ça et c'est le
sait le le la personne qui est dans le
coma et qui est nourri artificiellement
et avec un coeur artificiel etc
c'est le même principe là vous avez une
économie qui l'économie réelle qui est
par terre qui est qui est mort pour une
grande partie
et puis vous avez des injections
artificielle de nourriture qui font que
on a l'impression qu'il vit encore mais
mais malheureusement ils bougent plus et
donc c'est exactement là ce qu'on vous a
dit sur air france sur renault sur pie
j'en passe et des meilleurs et
qui sont des entreprises qui
comptablement et et parce que leur
business model est mauvais qui sont
mortes qui sont comptablement en
faillite et et on continue à faire
croire que mais comment vont-ils les
rembourser ils ne pourront pas les
rembourser parce qu'ils n'en ont pas une
activité qui leur permettra de
rembourser la dette et c'est la même
chose au niveau du pays
quand vous entendez monsieur le maire
qui vous annonce 6% de croissance pour
et qui vous dit c'est pas grave ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui de s'endetter jusqu'à
plus soit parce que on va avoir de la
croissance et que cette croissance va
rembourser la dette
mais c'est de la science fiction c'est
une aberration c'est bien que monsieur
le maire ne s'est pas compté mais à ce
point là c'est quand même difficile à
accepter
stéphane simon est ce qu'il aurait pas
mieux fallu finalement laissé ces
entreprises ou rire ou se faire racheter
par exemple bah écoutez leurs achats les
cessions fusions acquisitions cette
année les prévisions pour des grands
groupes comme goldman sachs ou jp morgan
et cetera ils vont véritablement si vous
permettez et devance gaufres et cette
année ça c'est sûr que les prises de
capital ou les augmentations de capital
il y en avoir dans tous les coins
mais si je reprends si vous voulez ce
qualité soulevé par olivier par rapport
au modèle le modèle il a 30 ans on le
connaît c'est un modèle néo keynésiens
faire du déficit pour faire des relances
en découplant de la dette
ce modèle a déjà été appliquée pour le
connaît dans l'histoire économique
notamment en grande bretagne dans les
années 46 77
il est clair que ça a toujours abouties
l'île saint-jean suis certain soin à
l'hyperinflation soit la dévaluation
général de l'ama n'est parce que les
dettes ne date pas d'hier il ya toujours
eu comme ça des états qui s'endettent
c'est le seul moyen qu'on a eu pour
rembourser ses dettes c'est bien entendu
une dévaluation général et là c'est la
fin de l'euro malheureusement et saura
lui de l'hyper agression qui nous
permettait tout simplement de rembourser
les dettes d'une façon
mais deux écrans économistes j'ai étudié
ça avec mes étudiants mais ont donné
leurs conclusions sur le l'hélicoptère
monétaire de milton friedman sais je
reviens parce que c'est vraiment de
rapport et deux économistes qui ont fait
parler d'eux et on les a malheureusement
encore un petit peu oublié ces en diable
est cuit kerman et il est clair qu'au
bout du compte ce modèle de d'ouvrir
comme ça un mot le quantitative easing
au delà des liens de ce qui est
supportable pour le bilan de la banque
centrale européenne va forcément aboutir
alors savoir quand est-ce que ça va
déclencher je peux pas vous dire mais en
tout cas on va vers de gros gros
problème et ça sera autre chose que le
dépôt de bilan de lehman brothers et
merrill lynch en 2007 rapidement à
messieurs avant de refermer cette
émission un mot sur le versement des
dividendes versé des dividendes ou
racheter des actions l'année de l'octroi
d'un prêt garanti par l'état est
impossible en revanche les entreprises
qui ont bénéficié de ce dispositif en
2020 pourront verser des dividendes à
leurs actionnaires est cette année en
si leur trésorerie le permet est ce
qu'il aurait fallu interdire de toute
manière le versement de dividendes sur
une durée par exemple plus longue
il est évident de toute façon mais vous
êtes si vous étiez arrivé
vous étiez arrivé à quelque chose de de
schizophrénique
juste avant le coc vide il fallait il
fallait voir ce qui se passait vous
aviez aux états unis plusieurs
entreprises qui avaient s'étaient
endettés pour payer du dividende
vous avez des entreprises qui
s'endettent pour racheter leurs propres
titres
en dehors je vous parle pas du prêt
garanti par l'état je vous parle d'avant
donc on était arrivé à quelque chose qui
est foncièrement malsain vous ne vous
endettez pas pour verser du dividende le
dividende c'est une partie du résultat
si vous ne faites pas de résultats à
priori vous n'avez pas à verser de
dividende
mais on était arrivé
aso à ce niveau là donc et vous aurez
toujours aux états unis ce que je vous
ai expliqué dans une autre émission vous
aurez ce phénomène où les entreprises
prennent l'argent qui est déversée par
les banques centrales pour racheter
leurs propres titres pour donner une
illusion de faire du résultat ce
qu'elles ne font pas réellement ou de
croissance de résultats donc oui
évidemment il faut interdire comme vous
avez quand vous prêtez de l'argent pour
sauver une entreprise ça veut dire que
l'entreprise ne fait pas de résultats de
toute façon et donc elle n'a pas à
verser de dividende
encore heureux qu'elles n'utilisent pas
le prêt qu'on leur fait pour verser du
dividende avec des résultats largement
négatif encore heureux mais c'est pas
c'est pas dit que ça continue longtemps
comme ça parce que je vous dit vous êtes
vous étiez déjà arrivé avant le coviva
une situation qui était inacceptable
c'était fait un bâtiment une réaction
rapidement oui bah pour les dividentes
c'est très clair la logique depuis une
trentaine d'années et qui continuent
d'ailleurs à s'accentuer c'est que et là
je reprends un tout petit peu les les
propos d'olivier c'est que la phase de
mondialisation a fait baisser les marges
et les valeurs ajoutées de l'europe des
entreprises européennes et américaines
on est en phase de désindustrialisation
qu'on n'a jamais vécu depuis ce breton
donc forcément quand les industriels
n'ont pas la possibilité par leurs
marges et la rentabilité de maîtriser
leur propre dividendes reversement de
réserve et cetera
il passe bel entendez par des fonds
d'investissement je les connais bien les
fonds d'investissement qui prennent des
parts pour un deux trois ou quatre ans
pour faire ce qu'on appelle l'effet de
levier
faut-il ne pas rémunérer ceux qui
prennent des risques
bah forcément les fonds d'investissement
de monde un rendement de leurs deux de
10 à 12% à l'année se fichant totalement
de savoir si véritablement l'entreprise
fait d'argent pas voilà on est dans une
contradiction de prix
contrôle du marché secondaire qui fait
une qui continuent d'ailleurs à faire
des effets de levier demandant des
dividendes et de l'autre côté une phase
qui malheureusement je crains la sortie
du communisme de désindustrialisation
trop importante de l'europe et des états
unis
voilà si beaucoup stéphane petit bon
d'avoir été parmi nous en cette émission
je rappelle que vous êtes enseignant en
économie et finance et puis
administrateur et risk managers dans un
fonds d'investissement olivier on
continue avec les tiroirs qu'avec les
questions cash et on commence tout de
suite avec la première question est
celle de tout ou à vélo les anglais ont
gagné quoi exactement ils ont perdu
l'irlande du nord ils ont perdu le
pouvoir de prendre les grandes décisions
concernant leurs économies celles qui
vont être prises à washington et
bruxelles
et ils ont réussi à négocier le commerce
des biens mais pas le commerce de leur
service tout ce qu'ils ont réussi à
faire c'est de s'imposer des sanctions
économiques
je pense que il n'a pas bien vu ce qui
s'était passé monsieur tout ou à vélo
non enfin franchement ils ont récupéré
leur leurs économies ils ont récupéré le
pouvoir de prendre des décisions parce
qu'aujourd'hui les décisions elles sont
prises à bruxelles et donc les
dirigeants des pleins principaux pays
européens ne sont que des marionnettes
donc là aujourd'hui
les le royaume uni a récupéré son
pouvoir de négociation
il fait d'ailleurs très bien et depuis
depuis un petit moment de conclure des
accords bilatéraux avec les principaux
pays
figurez vous monsieur tout ou à vélo que
il ya plein de pays qui ne sont pas dans
l'union européenne et qui vivent très
bien donc
safram plus ont passé la question d'alex
77 économiquement parlant si les causes
revenait dans le giro européen est ce
que ça lui serait profitable à l'ecosse
ou ou au à l'europe
et écoutez c'est pas c'est pas un
problème du break si ça fait très
longtemps que les écossais cherchent à
se libérer de l'emprise de du reste du
royaume uni donc c'est pas un problème
qui est venu avec le break site c'est
quelque chose qui est là depuis
longtemps maintenant sérieusement enfin
je veux dire personne aujourd'hui ne
peut ne peut envisager de dire que le
l'europe l'union européenne apporte quoi
que ce soit aux pays qu'ils intègrent
donc c'est une
c'est une erreur majeure on l'a vu le
coc vide a été un excellent exemple de
ça on a vu que au moment où on avait des
ennuis tout le monde
jouer sa carte et personne ne s'occupait
de ses petits camarades de jeu donc
franchement je pense que le break site
est une bonne chose
en tout cas pour la grande bretagne pour
nous c'est nettement moins le cas c'est
nous qui allons être défavorisés et
c'est pas eux et donc les cos qui
taperait à la porte de l'europe ce
serait franchement ridicule pour eux
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
pour poser vos questions à olivier
rendez vous sur les réseaux sociaux en
commentaire et des vidéos avec le
hashtag rt cash on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
en attendant olivier c'est à vous pour
le mot de la fin on écoute et débrancher
le malade ça sera mieux que d'essayer de
continuer à
nourrir un comateux